the layout shifter pattern is probably
the most responsive pattern with
multiple break points across several
different screen widths but the key to
this layout is the way that content
moves about instead of Reef lowing and
dropping below other columns flexbox
really shines here because we can use
the order CSS attribute amazing because
so much can change in each layout it
does require a bit more planning to
maintain I'll go for something a bit
more complex this time in order to get
the layout I want I've wrapped the light
blue div and the green div inside
container too I've made one small change
to the container class from the last
example and I've said its width to 100%
so that the element inside takes up the
full width when no breakpoint has been
hit only the default styles are applied
making each element 100% width stacked
on top of the other when the first media
query is hit at 500 pixels the
breakpoint changes the dark blue and the
container each to be width of 50% the
red div remains at 100% because we
haven't changed it at 600 pixels things
start to get really fun to get
everything to fit I need to change the
width on container 2 to 50% and the
width on dark blue and red to 25% each
next to change the order I need to
specify an order for each element
remember the default order value for an
element is 0 if I set order to negative
1 on the red div it'll appear first to
get the dark blue element to show up
last I need to set its value to anything
greater than 0 so 1 let's take a look in
the browser it's all stacked to start
but as it gets wider and hits the first
breakpoint the dark blue goes to the
left with light blue and green on the
right until finally it switches up again
nice